une dose de vaccin administrées dans le
couloir d'une université qui pourrait
avoir des impacts dans les restaurants
centres sportifs et cinémas du monde
entier pourront enfin profiter
pleinement des activités qui nous manque
c'est la question à laquelle chercheurs
et étudiants tentent de répondre dans
cette étude menée aux quatre coins des
états unis
le but déterminer si les gens qui ont
reçu le vaccin peuvent transmettre le
virus
ou pas les étudiants sélectionnés sont
vaccinés deux temps un premier groupe
dès maintenant un second en juillet
qu'au cours des prochains mois tous
seront dépistés quotidiennement certains
de leurs proches seront aussi suivies
selon chercheurs les étudiants ont
tendance à socialiser davantage ce
qu'ils ont fait de bons sujets pour
évaluer le degré de propagation du virus
pour les encourager à participer
on offre à ces jeunes qui ne font pas
partie des groupes prioritaires d'avoir
accès au vaccin
le hasard déterminera c'est leur
première dose sera administré maintenant
où cet été de quoi convaincre sept
participants qui étaient impatients
d'être vacciné question protéger les
eaux
les chercheurs font face à un défi pour
recruter des étudiants dans le cadre de
leurs études
c'est que depuis le début de la semaine
tous les adultes américains sont
admissibles à recevoir une dose du
vaccin ce qui inclut de nombreux
étudiants universitaires qui pourraient
être tentés de se faire vacciner plus
rapidement ailleurs compte tenu de la
demande être admissibles ne signifie pas
que vous obtiendrez un rendez-vous
immédiatement rappelle-t-il malgré ces
difficultés l'étude est donc sur les
rails
les premiers résultats sont attendus à
la fin de l'été l'espoir est que les
autorités puissent mieux juger du risque
que représente ou non certaines
activités dès l'automne cette
participante qui n'a jamais eu droit à
une session régulière espère que sa
contribution à l'étude lui permettra
d'enfin expérimenter la vie sur un
campus universitaire
ici rappelle bouvier oakley radio-canada
dans le maryland